voici la nonette nouvelle génération
vous souhaitez au magnésium cuivré fer
vitamine d ou encore en fibres l'idée
est née dans la tête de katherine
petitjean la patronne des lieux
attention ce pain d'épicés pas une
innovation mais une façon pour cette
société bicentenaire de rajeunir son
image
on sent bien que le consommateur il
souhaite des produits santé et moi même
en tant que consommatrice je suis adepte
de ce type de produits donc on allie
plaisirs gourmets avec avec la santé le
bien-être
ces petits gâteaux assure vitalité
sérénité et un bon transit
ça c'est du marketing mais pas
uniquement car depuis une loi de 2007
ces allégations de santé c'est-à-dire cv
inventé doivent être vérifiés par un
laboratoire
on a pris et plus de 400 personnes
divisées en trois groupes certains
avaient des problèmes de transit aux tab
et des problèmes de stress d'autres
avaient des problèmes de fatigue et puis
on leur a demandé de manger chacune la
nonette qui correspondait à leurs
besoins on les a suivis parfois pendant
deux mois ou trois mois et on a on a
effectivement démontré
que le bénéfice était véritablement
apporté par la nonette des aliments
enrichis en oligo éléments vitamines ou
fibre pourquoi pas selon cette
nutritionniste
mais il ne faut pas oublier l'essentiel
c'est bénéfique pour la santé c'est
d'avoir un régime alimentaire équilibré
donc ça nous ce travail qu'on fait au
quotidien c'est que les gens sachent à
peu près où mettre le curseur dans leur
alimentation en termes de voix dire de
fréquence de consommation de certains
produits
donc effectivement là quand on est sur
des produits qui sont avant tout des
gâteaux on fait attention à la fréquence
de consommation
et oui avec ou sans magnésium attention
au sucre et aux pois une honnête est
composée à 75 % de glucides